Give him a warm welcome Dr Jordan b
Peterson.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's very nice to be here and to see you
all come out to spend a couple of hours
thinking about difficult things.
There seems to be an appetite for that,
which is really something.
So let's exploit it.
So
I started working on the ideas that I
outlined in 12 rules for life while a
long time ago and really started when I
was about 13.
I was a junior high school student and
um,
I met this librarian who's kind of an
eccentric person,
very well educated person
and she,
we are used to hang around with my
delinquent friends in the library,
which tells you how eccentric the
librarian was because that's not
normally the place where the delinquent
kids hang out,
you know.
But she talked to us like we were adults
and that was,
what would you call it?
A refreshing.
That was a refreshing experience.
And
she knew that I liked to read and she
started giving me real books.
She gave me one day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich,
which was the first book published by Al
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn in the Soviet
Union,
and it's a story about the day of a
political prisoner in a,
in a,
in a work camp and brave new world,
and 1984 and animal farm and Ayn rand's
books,
which was quite interesting because she
was the wife of our member of parliament
who was the only member of the
opposition in our province and he was a
socialist,
an NDP new Democratic Party leader as a
matter of fact.
And,
but despite that,
she gave me Ayn rand's books because she
thought that I should be exposed to the
other side of the argument.
So I read atlas shrugged and,
um,
the fountain head and well,
she was the first person who helped me
discover literature,
let's say.
And while at the same time I got
interested in what had happened in Nazi
Germany.
And I wrote an essay about that when I
was about 13 or 14 about Auschwitz and
what had happened there.
And I never read that really never left
my mind.
I would say I think I read Viktor
Frankl's man's search for meaning at
that point,
which is a book I would highly
recommend.
I have a reading list on my website by
the way at Jordan Peterson Dotcom,
and so there's a variety of books there
that have really influenced me and I put
them up for other people's use
anyways.
I never what what I learned about
Auschwitz and about Nazi Germany never
really left my mind and because I
couldn't understand how people could act
that way,
how they could not only be possessed by
an ideology to the degree that the
Germans were very civilized country
Germany,
you know,
so it was I suppose even more
spectacular shock that something so
catastrophic happened there,
but it wasn't just the ideological
possession.
It was the cruelty and the gratuitous
cruelty in the service of that
ideological possession that I couldn't
understand.
It didn't.
I couldn't establish a relationship
between my own being and those patterns
of action.
And as I got older,
that concern transformed itself into an
obsession.
I would say not so much with what had
happened in Nazi Germany,
but with I think what happened,
what was happening as a consequence of
the collectivist philosophy per se,
which you might think of something that
manifested itself both on the right in
Nazi Germany and then on the left in all
the multitudinous and catastrophic
communist regimes that characterized the
bulk of the 20th century and they're
insane murderousness and that probably
culminated for me in the 19 seventies
when I Read Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag archipelago,
which is another book that everyone
should read because in some sense it
might be the defining document of the
20th century and the fact that everyone
in the West isn't familiar with that
book is actually a signal of our
catastrophic moral failing.
I would say.
Um,
I started writing this book called maps
of meaning in about 1985,
although it had been working on variance
of it before that.
And what I was trying to understand was
maybe the psychological
motivations for the Cold War.
Something like that.
Many of you are old enough to remember
what it was like in the 19 eighties.
We just went and visited the house in in
Reykjavik where Gorbachev and Reagan
met,
which was quite something to see and
when they decided they were going to
bring at least some of the insanity to
irrelative Hallt,
thank God,
and the eighties were a very contentious
time.
You know,
the Cold War sort of peaked in two at
two times.
That peaked in 1962 during the Cuban
missile crisis.
I don't know if you know this,
but when I visited a,
a nuclear missile site in Arizona
about 10 years ago,
it was a decommissioned missile site,
intercontinental ballistic missile.
Intercontinental ballistic missile is a
very large rockets and can go halfway
around the world and its ballistic,
which means it has the same function as
a bullet and the bullet is ballistic
because once you fire it,
it's gone.
You don't control it after it.
It leaves.
So once you launch a ballistic missile,
it's launched,
there's no calling it back.
And they told us they did a simulation
launch,
which was very eerie thing.
And so to launch a nuclear missile is a
big console.
It sort of looks like the star Trek
control a control module,
let's say,
and one person stands here and one
person stands about 20 feet away,
each have a key around their neck and
they put the key in the lock
simultaneously and then turn it for 10
seconds and at the end of 10 seconds the
missile is gone and that's that and they
both had their keys in the lock in 1962,
so and we came close again in 1984 when,
I don't know if you know this,
but the Soviet missile detection system
signal the launch of four or five
missiles from North America and a single
Russian soldier decided that it was a
false alarm and refused to push the
button would have resulted in major
retaliation.
He just died about a year ago.
You can read about him on wikipedia.
Anyways,
I read Solzhenitsyn in 1976 and that
made me,
me even I would say more obsessed with
what was happening in,
in on the world stage.
I was trying to understand why it was
that
the systems of belief that we inhabited.
Let's say one typifying the Soviet
Union,
and in similar states,
Mao's,
China,
North Korea,
wonderful places like that versus the
West.
We each had our own way of construing
the world,
the ways of construing the world were
set at odds with one another and the
fact that they were set at odds with one
another appeared to be so significant
that we've armed ourselves with
50,000
harder hydrogen bombs on each side.
Something like that.
And I don't know how much you knew about
a hydrogen bomb.
You know,
you know about atomic bombs,
you know that a hydrogen bomb has an
atomic bomb for the trigger.
Right?
So,
so like the atom bomb that was dropped
on Hiroshima,
that was something that was a fission
bomb,
not standard atomic bomb,
the first generation,
but hydrogen bomb is incontestably more
powerful than that.
And we were producing them in the tens
of thousands.
It's not like we don't have any now,
but it was really some insanity in the
19 eighties and people seem to have a
very itchy trigger finger.
So I was very confused about this in two
ways.
One from a psychological perspective,
because by that time I just started
decided to study psychology instead of
political science,
which was my original major.
I get,
I got disenchanted with political
science because I didn't believe that
people were fundamentally motivated by
economic issues.
I still don't believe that that's true.
They're motivated by whatever they're
motivated by.
It can't be captured by economics,
not not precisely.
It was very curious about what it was
that was so important about a belief
system that people would risk putting
the entire planet to the torch to ensure
that their particular motive construing
the world prevailed is an interesting
psychological problem.
What was so important about belief
system that would justify destroying
everything,
let's say,
or risking destroying everything because
that was certainly the situation we put
ourselves in
and more to the point of I guess,
or equally to the point I was interested
in two other things.
One was
were these differences in belief
systems?
Just arbitrary,
and that's actually a postmodern
question.
I didn't know that at the time now
because you might say the postmodernists
do say there's a very large number of
ways of interpreting the world and it
isn't obvious how you determine which of
those ways are correct and so perhaps
you can't determine that any of them are
correct and then as a consequence of
your inability to determine if any of
them are correct,
then you have to turn to something like
power dispute to establish which
interpretation is going to take
precedence.
And I would say in a nutshell,
that's a postmodern is theory.
Now that's tainted to some degree with
Marxist preconceptions,
but we won't get into that.
But that's basically the idea and it's
an idea with a certain amount of
justification.
There is a very large number of ways of
interpreting the world and it isn't
obvious which way or ways are right or
why they're right.
So it's a complicated problem.
And so I was curious is like,
was this merely a difference of opinion?
The West had a certain set of axioms
that it was acting out in the world and
the Soviet bloc and the rest of the
communist countries have another set of
axioms and they were both arbitrary and
it was a matter of power or was there
something deeper at stake?
So that was question number two.
Question number three was,
was there an to brutal combat?
Was there an alternative way of solving
the dispute too brutal group combat,
something like that and because I always
believed that if you understood the
problem that you could solve it.
In fact that if,
if when you analyze the problem,
a solution didn't emerge from the
analysis,
then you actually didn't understand the
problem.
And so I thought if I
delved into the problem deeply enough,
then maybe I could figure out what might
constitute a solution.
Assuming there was such a thing because
I couldn't.
I knew after writing a fair bit of it
that we were.
That there was a real problem because
you can get belief systems that are
locked in combat and then obviously the
terrible consequence of that is the
combat.
But then I also knew,
and this was probably more from reading
Nicha than anything else,
that if your belief system collapses,
you might say,
well,
I don't want to fight with you about
whose belief system is correct.
I'll just let my mind go.
But the problem is if you let your
belief system go,
then you're swamped by nihilism and
hopelessness.
And that's not helpful.
First of all,
it's very.
It's not helpful psychologically because
it produces emotional pain and anxiety
and maybe at unbearable levels you can't
have a pointless life.
It's,
it's,
it's a suffering,
a pointless life is pointless suffering
and people can't sustain that without
becoming demoralized.
That's only where they start.
Demoralized,
bitter,
cruel,
resentful,
angry,
hostile,
murderous,
genocidal.
Like all those things follow one from
another.
If,
if things are sufficiently hopeless,
scared,
just let your belief system go.
But if you're locked into it and there's
another one that you're competing with,
then the consequences war.
It's like,
so what is it nihilism on the one hand
in war on the other that didn't seem
like especially given outcome of like
say the Third World War that neither of
those seemed like acceptable
alternatives,
but I couldn't see any other.
I couldn't see that there was anything
else other than those two alternatives
and so that's what I tried to layout in
in this book.
Maps of meaning and most of the thoughts
that I expressed in 12 rules for life,
not all of them and in the lectures that
I've done that have become popular on
Youtube,
were all developed during the 15 year
period that I worked on that book and I
worked on it.
I would say obsessively really.
I wrote about three hours a day and I
thought about it for pretty much 12
other hours and so I was thinking
constantly.
It was not an obvious why,
but.
Well,
I told you why for some reason all of
that manifested itself to me as a
cardinal problem,
but I concluded and tried to lay out the
rationale for this,
the,
the fight between these two belief
systems,
but let's.
Let's look at the belief systems.
It's not communism versus the West.
It's not communism versus the free
market.
It's different than that.
It's collectivism in it's far right
form,
let's say the far right form of the
Nazis and the far left form of the
radical leftists,
the communists sets collectivism versus
individualism.
That's the fundamental conflict and
there are variants of the collectivist
viewpoint,
but it doesn't matter.
They can be grouped under the rubric of
Collectivism.
There's important differences,
but we don't have to get into that with
the western take wasn't collectivist.
It was individualist and the central
idea of the West was that although
people are obviously obviously aggregate
into groups and many different groups
because all of you are members of very
of many different groups,
ethnicities,
genders,
sexes,
races,
family groups,
community groups.
You can be grouped a very large number
of ways and and you tend towards the
adoption of something approximating a
group identity because you know,
you take care of your family and you're
a member of your community and you have
a certain amount of justifiable
patriotism in relationship to your
state.
The group identity is definitely part of
who you are.
The question is what is the fundamental
defining characteristic of who you are
and the collectivist definition is that
you are the Avatar of a collective and
that's fundamentally who you are,
but the western perspective is not that.
The Western perspective is that despite
the fact that people have an individual
level and a collective level,
the individual level is to be regarded
as paramount.
You're to be treated above all else
above all,
as an individual.
Now,
and I looked into that very deeply and I
thought that isn't arbitrary.
It's actually correct.
That's the right way of looking at the
world,
and then you might say,
well,
what do you mean the right way?
And of course that's the right question
because that is the question.
If something's the right way of looking
at something,
well why is it the right way of looking
at it?
But I want to put a little spin on that
too because usually when we talk about
individualism in the West,
at least in the modern world,
maybe let's say for the last 50 years or
something like that.
Maybe it's after World War Two,
I don't know exactly the parameters.
It doesn't matter.
Certainly since the 19 sixties when we
think about the tradition of
individuality in the west,
we think about the tradition of
individual rights and there's a problem
with that because
the fundamental individual tradition of
the West is not individual rights and
rights have a problem.
Rights are sort of like you're
privileged compared to other people.
I have these rights and don't tread on
them that that wall's me off and makes
me privileged.
In some sense.
It means that I have the right to do
things,
have the right to pursue my own
interests.
I have the right to pursue happiness,
for example,
that's explicitly laid out in the
American system.
The rights or what is special about me,
and so when you look at individuality or
individualism from that perspective,
you can think about it as a selfish idea
and it's often criticized by
collectivists precisely for that
selfishness,
but the fundamental idea of the
individual in the West isn't predicated
on rights.
Even though that's important,
it's predicated on responsibility.
Right?
So your role as an individual in the
West isn't to be the bearer of rights of
intrinsic rights,
even though those are important.
Your responsibility as an individual in
the west is to bear the responsibility
of an individual and it's in bearing
that responsibility that you set
yourself right and your family right and
you keep the state on track.
It's not from expressing your rights,
it's from shouldering your
responsibility and I would say that the
reason that you have rights in the West
is so that you can shoulder your
responsibility.
It's not the other way around.
It's so that you can do what's best on
your behalf and in that manner,
do what's best on your family's behalf
and in that manner contribute to the
degree that you can to the community and
that if you do all those things
simultaneously,
which means to accept the responsibility
for that,
then things move ahead as well as they
can move ahead.
Which doesn't necessarily mean well
because life is very difficult and
there's no sure way through it.
There's only less bad approaches.
That might be a way of thinking about it
and the least bad approach you can
manage is to shoulder your
responsibility as an individual and
that's the and I would say that one of
the things that drives the collectivist
ethos,
which is often formulated in terms of
compassion for the oppressed,
which is something we'll talk about a
little bit later,
is actually a deep desire to at all
costs,
avoid that responsibility and it's no
wonder because the responsibility is
overwhelming.
Say The world fundamentally is a tragic
place,
right?
It's a place in which each of us is
broken and it's contaminated by the ever
present reality of betrayal and
malevolence and to shoulder the
responsibility first for even admitting
to that and second,
for assuming that you are duty bound,
let's say to do something about that.
Well,
that's a task that anyone who has his or
her eyes open should be leery of
accepting.
And I would say,
well,
perhaps there's no credible reason for
accepting it except that every other
alternative is worse.
And so that's a brutal fact.
So the antidote to collectivism is
individualism,
but it's not the individualism of the
privileged person with rights.
It's the terrible burden of the
individual who determines that he or she
will shoulder their responsibility to
that most.
So I developed that idea in maps of
meaning
that and I made a lot of lectures about
that book,
many of which are on Youtube,
some of which have become widely viewed,
I would say by one hundreds of thousands
of people now.
And so that's.
And that course always had a dramatic
effect on my students and their most
typical comment.
There's two classes of typical comments
that I got from students about my maps
of meaning courses and it's the same
comments that I get from people now when
they come and talk to me about my
lectures.
The first comment is,
and this is about maybe a quarter of the
people,
is that
watching the lectures are taking the
course,
enabled them to put words to things they
knew,
they knew but didn't know how to say.
And so.
And that's fine because that was an ex
that was actually an explicit purpose of
the writing.
And the course,
and the second is that it helped people
straightened out their lives and that's
also not that surprising to me because a
lot of what I integrated into that book
and the lectures and the lectures were
also associated with my personality
course were ideas from the great
clinical psychologists and psychiatrists
of the 20th century.
There was a dozen of them or so,
or maybe 20,
who were all outstanding geniuses,
have slightly different types who
learned all sorts of things about how
people could put themselves self
together properly as individuals,
and if you learn about those things,
they're actually really helpful.
That's not surprising because they sit
at the core of an entire domain of
science and art,
let's say,
devoted to improving people's individual
lives.
I wove the responsibility idea into 12
rules because that's really what it is.
In some sense,
it's a a call to the voluntary adoption
of maximal individual responsibility and
it's a psychological work,
not a political work.
Now,
I think the reason that it's attracted
so much political attention,
let's say some of which couldn't log
referred to in the introduction is,
well,
there's two reasons.
One is because I took what might be
regarded as a political stance about
some compelled speech legislation in
Canada.
I never regarded that as a political
move because I regarded the legislation
itself as something that wasn't a
political move.
I regarded it as an attempt by the
politicians to jump outside their domain
of acceptable conduct into the
philosophical or even the theological
realm because you don't mess with the
idea of free speech in a Western country
and there's very sophisticated reasons
for that and it doesn't matter what your
reasons for doing it are.
You don't go there and so,
but it happened to be the more radical
leftists that were pushing this forward
and because I objected to it than it was
in their interest to assume that I must
be the worst sort of right wing die hard
I suppose because otherwise they'd have
to contend with my actual arguments.
And so it's simpler just to shoot the
messenger than to contend with the
arguments.
And you know,
if you stand up and say there's
something wrong in a place like Canada
where most things aren't wrong,
then it's reasonable.
Also for people to assume there must be
something wrong with you because most of
the time there isn't anything wrong with
the country and so a certain amount of
testing is a reasonable thing for people
to do.
I guess the other element of this that's
political in some sense though is that
within the collectivist viewpoint,
this is something that's very
interesting with regard to free speech.
I didn't really figure this out until a
couple of weeks ago and although the
radical leftists and you see this
particularly in the United States now,
although the Americans have a very
strong tradition of free speech,
the radical leftists are opposed to
freedom of speech,
but that's not really right.
It's not the way to think about.
In the radical leftist collectivist view
of the world.
There's actually no such thing as free
speech.
It's in worst criticism then than
opposing it because the collectivists
believed that you're nothing but an
Avatar of your group.
First of all,
there is no you.
You're defined by your group membership
and then the world is a landscape of
groups each vying for predominance and
that's what there is and it's and so
when you say that you're speaking your
mind,
that isn't something that you can do
from the collectivist view point.
What you're doing is acting as an
unconscious Avatar of the power demands
of your group.
There is no you.
There was no free speech.
There's no your opinion.
There's no facts for that matter.
Everything is to be viewed in
relationship to the power struggle
between groups that even in principle
cannot communicate and so the other
reason that I detest let's say the
collectivist viewpoint is because I see
that it leads nowhere but to conflict
because if people cannot speak as
individuals between groups,
then all they can do is submit or fight.
Those are the options,
right?
Negotiation,
capitulation or warfare.
Those are the options and the only
process that allows for negotiation in
the absence of capitulation or conflict.
His speech,
because we can talk over our differences
and that discussion is going to be
contentious because we actually have
differences,
but compared to the contentiousness of
not talking over the differences,
it's a walk in the park.
You know?
I saw something quite remarkable when I
was in London a month and a half ago.
I was on this political show and one of
the things they did in this section that
didn't have anything to do with me was
to show a bunch of clips from the the,
the.
There's a question period that the
British have evolved where the
opposition can go after the prime
minister and the woman that was
appearing with me on the show had
written a book about that called Punch
and Judy,
if I remember correctly,
and they showed a bunch of clips of
English MPs attacking the prime minister
and the prime minister's response all
the way from Thatcher forward.
It was absolutely vicious in the way
that well-educated British people can be
vicious,
which is very oppressive form of
viciousness and was no holds barred.
Verbal combat,
and you might think,
well,
isn't that horrible?
Because it's certainly rife,
let's say with microaggressions,
but it's not horrible because none of
them had their hands around each other's
necks,
right?
It was all civilized.
It was everyone was standing where they
were supposed to stand and they were
hurling invective and making criticisms
and making accusations and defending
themselves and all of that,
but it was all contained within the
peaceful confines of this,
of the house of parliament,
and that's a miracle.
Really.
It's a miracle and the British are
particularly good at that,
and so you leave free speech alone
because the alternative to free speech
is capitulation or conflict,
and unless you want one of those or both
and you might,
then you don't interfere with the
mechanism that enables people's people
to state the nature of their reality and
to clarify that and to negotiate with
others even though that negotiation is
painful and emotionally demanding and
threatening and anxiety provoking and
aggression instigating and all of those
things,
because the alternative is far worse.
I wove the idea of individual
responsibility through through 12 rules.
While we might say we might begin by
thinking about how that's related to the
idea of free speech.
It's like
you have to find your way in the world,
let's say with all of your peculiarities
or idiosyncrasies and your differences
and the way you do that is by acting in
the world,
but the way you prepare to act is by
thinking and really what you're doing
when you're thinking.
So philosopher named Alfred North
Whitehead who said something very
intelligent about thinking.
He said that the reason we think is so
that our thoughts can die instead of us.
Right?
And it's a Darwinian idea.
So the way animals adapt to the world
across time is that animals produced
variants,
variant offspring,
many of them,
and most of them were unsuccessful and
die,
but a few of them are successful enough
in that time and place to reproduce.
And so the animal keeps living across
the millennia varying slightly as it
does.
So to adapt to the transformations of
the environment.
Human beings do the same thing,
but we also have figured out how to
abstract that.
And so what we do when we think is that
we produce a fictional world that's an
simulation of the real world and we
populate that simulated world with
simulations of us and then we let those
simulations play out in the simulated
world and the ones that are successful,
we embody and act out and the ones that
are unsuccessful,
we abandoned and let die and we do that
when we're thinking in dreams and we'd
do that when we think in stories and we
even do that when we think in words.
Although it's not as obvious when you
argue internally,
which is what you do when you think you
have an Avatar that manifests itself as
one point of view and an Avatar that
manifests itself as another and you let
them engage in conflict and the one that
loses you let go of.
That's a sacrifice.
And if you're discussing something with
someone and it's important that you both
put your viewpoints forward and you
analyze the consequences of the dispute
and then you walk away with any luck,
why is there then you were so that you
can embody a motive being that's more
likely to be successful and you do that
in part in large part by exercising your
freedom of speech and you might think,
well,
why?
Freedom of speech and freedom of
thought.
And the answer to that is don't be
thinking that you think because thinking
is very hard and most people can't think
at all,
and even if you can think you're not
very good at it,
I mean think about what you have to do
technically to think.
First of all,
you have to formulate the problem that's
hard enough and you have to formulate it
precisely.
Then you have to generate multiple
potential solutions to the problem and
then you have to let those solutions
argue
into a hierarchy internally.
And so you have to be able to tolerate
that stress,
right?
You can't just be one thing if you're
going to think because thinking isn't
just saying that.
What I think is right,
that's not thinking at all.
Thinking is questioning whether or not
what you think is right is right and
that's really hard.
It's very demanding and so and you can
do that to some degree,
but you're not as good at it as you
think.
Even if you're a pretty good thinker.
Mostly the way you think is by talking
and you talk and mostly when you talk
and think it's contentious as you know
if you've ever had an intimate
relationship with someone because an
intimate relationship,
if it,
if it has any worth at all,
is a place where there's tremendous
contention but it's bounded within
something approximating mutual respect
and the willingness to continue to play
the game across time and the reason that
an intimate relationship as contentious
as.
Because life is very,
very difficult and people are different
and we face extraordinarily complex
problems together.
Like how to make a living and how to.
How to operate properly in our careers
and how to rank order the importance of
our careers.
And how to manage our domestic economies
and how to discipline our kids and
whether or not to have kids and how to
enter middle age and how to grow old
gracefully and how to live productively
and where to vacation and all of these
things which are extraordinarily
difficult problems and the only way that
we can solve them is by butting heads to
some degree and communicating freely
about what the possibilities are and
negotiating a solution and that's
thinking and in order to do that
thinking,
you have to be able to speak freely and
you certainly have to be willing to
offend someone.
I mean,
of all the stupid questions I've ever
been asked by journalists,
the question,
what makes you think you have the right
to offend someone by what you say is by
far the most miraculously ignorant.
And I say that because,
well,
no,
it just,
it just sets me back on my heels to some
degree because I think,
well,
what's your claim here?
Your claim is.
Your first claim is we could
hypothetically discussed something
important without one of us getting
upset.
It's like,
that's not gonna happen.
If you ever discussed anything important
with anyone,
including just discussing it with
yourself,
not only are you going to get upset,
you're going to get so upset that you
probably won't even do it.
You know,
you think,
well,
I have a difficult problem.
What do you.
What's your first reaction?
Well,
I'm going to sit right here and think
about that.
It's like,
no,
that isn't your reaction.
Your reaction is to go like play a video
game or watch a youtube video or or
vacuum your bedroom or do the dishes or
whatever you can do.
Not to think about that.
That's what you're going to do.
So you know,
and then if you're going to have a
discussion with your wife or your
husband or your kids and it's about
something important.
It's like if you're a normal person,
your heart rate goes up and it's like
it's demanding and then you have to
think it through and then you're
probably wrong and you're going to
stumble over your words and God only
knows if you're going to reach a
solution and you can't tell if it's
going to mean the end of your damn
relationship and like the catastrophe
lurks everywhere when you're discussing
difficult issues and the rule is
something like,
but you can't offend anyone.
It's like,
well then okay,
fine.
Then you never get to talk about
anything that's important with anyone
ever including yourself.
So like that's supposed to be the rule.
Then you think,
well even if it's not quite that bad,
it's like let's say,
so here I'm addressing about 850 people,
something like that.
It's like,
what's the probability that I could talk
about anything that any of you would
ever want to listen to for more than
about 15 seconds,
you know,
that would grip your interests without
me or offending at least one person in
this room with each sentence.
And there's a thousand people in here.
You know,
and some people are unbelievably easy to
offend,
there's that.
They're just looking for a reason to be
offended,
so,
so there's that problem.
But if we're going to deal with things
that are,
that are solid and contentious and why,
talk about things that we already all
agree on.
We've already solved those problems.
We can only really talk about things we
don't agree on.
It's the only thing worth talking about.
Well of course everyone's going to be
offended.
And so for a journalist to ask that,
it's like,
what the Hell's with you?
What?
What planet do you inhabit?
Don't you understand that your entire
discipline is predicated on not only
your right to offend someone,
but the responsibility that you have to
offend people.
It's like that's it's
thinking is an offensive act,
which is why tyrants hated,
right?
Because one of the rules and tyranny is
don't think why?
Because I already know all the answers
and you're supposed to accept my answers
as the tyrant,
and so there's no need for your
thinking.
And you might be saying,
well,
my life isn't going as well as it could.
And the tyrant says,
well,
you don't get to think that because in
my utopian tyranny,
everything's perfect,
and if you're suffering,
that means you're politically suspect
because you're suffering,
your inability to recognize that the
utopia has already manifested itself.
Your unhappiness is actually a political
crime,
but if you just keep it to yourself,
well we'll let you keep your head.
But if you have the the.
If you're driven to the extreme where
you have to express the fact you're
unhappy,
perhaps that your child doesn't have
enough to eat,
then it's off to the Gulag with you and
all your family as well because there'll
be no thinking here.
And even if there is,
they'll certainly be no talking.
So here's something that happened
recently in Venezuela.
This is worth thinking about for all the
people who harbor collectivist Utopian
Dreams,
Venezuela,
the Venezuelan government.
About two months ago,
this was reported in the New York Times,
which is not a newspaper,
I would say that would be intrinsically
biased against Venezuela,
said that it was now illegal to diagnose
the cause of a child's death in a
Venezuelan hospital as starvation.
Because the Venezuelans,
Venezuelan government's answer to the
problem of children starving was to make
it illegal to notice it in hospitals.
And that's a tyranny,
right?
That's a place where thought is not
allowed.
That's a place where free speech is not
So it seems to me that that's not a good
place to go to say the least.
And we've gone there many times in the
last hundred and 50 years and we should
perhaps think very hard about whether or
not we ever want to go there again.
Well,
the first rule in 12 rules for life is
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and I want to tell you a little bit
about the world in which that rule
applies and it's our world,
but it isn't necessarily the world that
you think of when you think of our
world.
Although it's the world,
you know,
it's funny because it's a world you
know,
but you don't know.
You know it.
It's a world that presents itself to you
in literary form and in mythological
foreman and symbolic form.
And you all understand it,
but you can't articulate it.
But I can articulate some of it.
How many of you have seen the lion king?
Okay,
how many of you haven't?
so that's a better question.
Hardly you guys should see the lion king
because obviously there's something
wrong with you.
So,
so,
and in any ways.
I want to tell you about the world of
the lion king.
Now,
one of the things I want you to notice
is that when you go see that movie or
when you show it to your kids,
when you watch it at home,
I don't care what you fall into it,
and that's very strange because first of
all,
it's not a world.
It's drawings,
right?
It's animated drawings of a world.
It's very low resolution and the
creatures aren't human.
They're animals.
You've all noticed that no doubt and the
world is magical because things happen
in it that aren't the sorts of things
that obviously happened in the real
world,
but you don't care about any of that.
You don't care that the animals talk.
You don't care that the lions are kings.
All of that makes perfect sense to you.
And that means that which is a very
strange thing,
which it means that the manner in which
the characters are represented and the
world that they inhabit is somehow
familiar to you because otherwise you
wouldn't fall into it and you wouldn't
even.
And you'd noticed that what you're doing
is so strange because it really is so
strange.
So imagine the opening of the lion king.
So what happens is that the camera pans
over the Great African plain and you see
all the animals gathering,
right?
They're all coming together and there's
this kind of thrilling Black Gospel
music going on in the background with an
African beat and so,
and it's really well done.
The opening of that movie and then the
camera pans up like,
like it's revealing something and you
see this structure that's known in the
movie as pride rock.
And so it's this structure that rises up
above the plane and it's shaped like
it's a mountain essentially.
Although it's not,
it's just a rock,
but it's a high place.
It's a place that you can,
that you can view everything from.
Right?
So it's a place that it's a place from
which you can get an overview,
it's a place from which you can see,
and you're introduced to the king's
little bird whose name I don't remember
at the moment,
and he's the eyes of the king.
So the king is obviously something that
has eyes because he has a bird and the
bird can fly around from up above and
see everything and report to him.
So whatever the king is is associated
with the bird.
Just like horace,
the ancient Egyptian God was associated
with a Falcon.
In fact,
for exactly that reason,
falcons can see better than any other
creature by the way,
better even than human beings.
And we have very good eyesight.
So the king is the creature who can see
and the king is Elian.
And the reason the lions that king is
because the lions at the top of the food
chain,
that's part of it.
But the line is a solar beast.
He has a main.
He's associated with the sun he's
associated with the daytime is
associated with power and majesty and
strength.
And it's not a mouse that's king right?
It's not a rat,
it's,
it's a,
it's a lion and you think,
well obviously the lion is king.
You know,
everyone knows that even though animals
don't have kings in case you didn't
notice,
so it's not self evident that it should
be the lion,
and then the lion is on the rock in the
sun,
right?
So the rock sticks up above everything
else and the lion is there and the lion
is a paternal line and he has a mate and
the scene opens with them giving birth
and so it's a nativity scene and so,
and that's painfully obvious if you
watch it with a little bit of
detachment,
it's entity scene and Rififi who's the
Shaman priest lifts up the new Messiah
to the sun and when that happens,
the music swells and all of the animals
go don't own their knees.
And it's a very.
And then the,
there's a drum beat and the,
the words the lion king come up on stage
and it's beautifully done.
It's beautifully done.
They they pan up to the revelation of
the lion cub to the sun two or three
times,
and it's really,
it's really emotional moment and it's
because all of these levels of symbolism
lock in at the same time you have the
the environment,
the field where all the animals
gathered,
so all the animals are gathering to
review the revelation of something
transcendent and the revelation of
what's transcendent is the birth of the
new hero to the king and Queen on the
rock above the plane,
and there's a universal truth in that,
which is why the animators worked as
hard as they did to make that scene and
why it opens.
What was one of the most spectacularly
successful movies of all time.
And the way the filmmakers do it is when
Rafiki holds up the the infant Simba,
the clouds break and the sun shines on
it,
and that's the culminating moment and
that's the revelation of the identity of
the newborn hero with the consciousness
of the sun.
And so we're light creatures.
We're daytime creatures.
We're visual creatures,
right?
We're,
we're not.
We don't.
We're not nocturnal.
The night is when we're unconscious,
the day is when we're conscious and the
terminology that we use that's
associated with the furtherance of our
consciousness is illumination and
enlightenment,
and so there's a tight relationship
between waking up and letting the light
shine in and developing and
consciousness and the association
between the rays of the sun and the
lifting up of the infant is the
association,
the ancient association between the hero
who defeats the forces of darkness and
the Sun itself,
and you all know all of that,
which is why that opening works and why
it sets the scene for the rest of the
movie.
And what's the rest of the movie?
Well,
we can think about the landscape.
First of all,
there's a scene where Simba,
his father,
takes him up on top of pride rock and
tells him that his kingdom,
that he's the king and his kingdom
extends as far as the light touches.
So the landscape is a place with a
pyramid in it.
There at the top of the pyramid on a
plane that's circumscribed by the light
and outside the light is darkness.
And so the the mythological landscape in
which this story reveals itself is light
versus darkness or order versus chaos,
and the reason for that is because that
is our landscape.
We inhabit pyramid structures.
Those are hierarchies of other
hierarchies.
I think in our society,
those are mostly hierarchies of
competence.
We,
we,
we inhabit hierarchical structures on a
plane that's defined,
defined by our understanding,
surrounded by what we do not comprehend,
and that's the universal human world.
And that hierarchy itself is a
cooperative structure that enables us to
live with a certain amount of peace in
productivity together and also to
establish a value system with whatever
is that the pinnacle of the hierarchy
regarded as whatever's most valuable.
Now think about what happens in the lion
king.
It's a,
it's a voyage into what's most valuable.
It's an examination of what's most
valuable.
Now
the old kingdom is threatened by scar.
Scar is the evil king of the evil
brother of the king.
The king is the PR,
the entity that inhabits the pinnacle of
the pyramid.
The king always has an evil brother and
you knew that as well,
and the reason for that is that there is
no hierarchy that's so pristine that it
isn't threatened by corruption and scars
presented as a resentful intellect,
and that's a very common trope as well.
That's the evil scientist idea.
It's not the only.
Only the evil scientist idea.
It's the mad scientist.
It's the evil genius.
God.
How many movies with a mythological
substrate have come out in the last 20
years that prominently feature an evil
genius?
It's like there's dozens of them.
There's an inexhaustible hunger for that
representation,
meaning the last avengers movie,
you had fat it toast,
right?
He was basically the spirit of death.
Who was an evil genius who thinks that
mass extinction is the answer to the
population problem of let's say the
world.
Something to think about very seriously.
While the reason for that is that this
estate is always threatened by
malevolence always.
The hierarchy can always be become
corrupt and tyrannical,
and that those are the forces of
malevolence.
Let's say they're conspiring behind the
scenes tend to tilt every hierarchy
towards tyranny and the proper attitude
to take towards that universal truth is
to stay in the light and keep your damn
eyes open and so well what happens in
the lion king is that the evil brother
overthrows the rightful king,
and that again is an unbelievably common
idea.
You see that idea echo throat,
the mythological landscape for
centuries,
and the reason for that is it happens
all the time.
That's what happened in Nazi Germany.
That's what's happened in most of the
tyrannical societies of the world,
and most societies in the world are
tyrannical.
There's always the possibility that the
hierarchies that we live in will become
corrupt and counterproductive,
and there's multiple reasons for that,
but there is summed up in the
malevolence of the arrogant intellect.
It's something like that.
That's it.
That's a very common idea.
That's the character of Milton Satan,
by the way,
because he's the ultimate in arrogant
intellect.
Milton,
Satan is the figure who believes that
his knowledge is sufficient to do
without the transcendent,
to do without the idea that there's
something beyond or that there's still
something to learn.
All I know is all that I need to know,
which is exactly the belief of the
fundamental tyrant.
The evil brother of the king kills the
king.
Simba loses his father.
Well,
that's another common idea because
everyone loses their father in some
sense.
People grow up and become cynical as
teenagers and the reason they become
cynical as teenagers is because they see
that the corruption of the state is
sufficient to undermine their confidence
in the benevolence of the state and they
get cynical prematurely because what the
hell do you know when you're a teenager,
but you're encouraged in your cynicism
frequently in our culture,
which is a very bad idea.
You know,
I mean,
even though it is the case that the
structure is always threatened by
malevolence,
let's say,
and and human weakness.
Simba ends up fatherless and lost and
alienated from his kingdom,
just like King Arthur.
It's the same story.
The king is often the rightful king is
often dissociated from his kingdom and
forced to occupy a domain that's outside
the kingdom and that's what happens to
Simba.
He loses his father and what happens,
he's.
He adopts the lifestyle of an impulsive
adolescent.
That's what happens,
and so he's out there in no man's land
with his useless teenage friends doing
nothing of any good except living for
the moment,
and that's the nihilistic retreat from
the corrupt state and no wonder,
and you might say,
well,
if the state is corrupt,
why should I participate in it's
maintenance?
Why should I do anything that's useful?
If all I'm doing is furthering the
development of a corrupt state,
and I would say the message in the most
pathological university disciplines the
activist disciplines,
that's exactly the message that they're
particularly putting out two young men,
which is you live in a corrupt
patriarchy,
and that means any attempts that you
make to further yourself in this life as
an individual with regards to your
family,
another corrupt patriarchal institution
with regards to marriage or career,
that all that is is furthering the
corrupt patriarchy.
Everything you do that you think is good
in the productive sense is actually
doing nothing but contributing to this
catastrophic,
tyrannical patriarchy,
very demoralizing,
but also opens the door for you to be as
useless as you possibly can because
there's always a temptation in that
direction because it's easier and you
can justify it by saying,
well,
if I did anything productive,
all he would be doing is furthering the
dominance of the corrupt system anyways,
and if you haven't met people who think
that way,
then you haven't met very many people
because that's an unbelievably common
way of thinking and it's an excuse,
but it's.
It's also a logical reaction to the
confusion of competence with power.
That's part and parcel of the
collectivist landscape,
so Simba grows up so to speak,
gets older,
at least playing this impulsive day to
day game.
Rule seven in my book is due.
What is meaningful?
Not what is expedient,
and of course,
symbols.
Lifestyle outside the rightful kingdom
is nothing but expedience.
It's impulsive pleasure,
and that lasts until,
until what?
Until his old girlfriend shows up Nela
and she's been dealing with the
catastrophe of the state and maybe
that's because
women,
the demands of family fall heavier on
women at least initially and so there
are more sensitive to the catastrophe of
the state.
Now let's shows up and says to Simba,
what the hell do you think you're doing?
You're useless.
I liked you when you were a kid.
Here you are.
You're completely useless and
everything's falling apart and the state
has become corrupt and there isn't
enough to eat and there's things that
need to be done and he falls in love
with her of course,
probably because she criticizes him and
and then he's deeply ashamed of himself
because she rejects him because he's
useless and so she should reject him
because he's useless and if she didn't
then he'd never figured out why I was
useless and do something about it.
And that's when he meets his father.
Remember,
there's an initiation seen there.
The wise old baboon who was supposed to
be a fool and in the early drafts of the
movie guides him down under ground so
that he can reflect upon himself,
which is what he does in a pool down in,
in the underworld,
and what he sees reflected in his own
face is the spirit of his dead father.
Mature face symbol looks like this,
right?
He looks like a deer,
caught in headlights.
The animators have done a really good
job of capturing that naive and sort of
rotten old adolescent innocence.
It's outlived its utility and but his
father has a very set face which means
he's integrated his aggression and he
sees his father in the water and then he
sees his father in the sky and his
father says,
you've forgotten who you are.
Wake the hell up.
Grow the hell up there or things to fix.
There are.
There are things to fix.
There's responsibilities to take on and
so
simplest rather shocked by this
encounter and decides to leave his false
adolescent paradise and to go back to
the catastrophic.
Lee demolished state and he takes his
friends and he sees this place that
where there's nothing but starvation and
cruelty and malevolence and tyranny,
and he fights a battle against evil and
he reclaims his kingdom and as soon as
that happens,
the rain falls and the plants grow and
harmony is restored and that's fascist
mysticism by the way,
so it seems to appeal to a very large
number of people given the popularity of
that movie.
And what is that?
What's it called?
A responsibility.
It's a fundamental call to
responsibility,
right?
Is that it is the case that we live in a
field.
It's defined by the extent of our
vision.
It is the case that we live in a
hierarchical structure on that plane.
It is the case that there's a kingship
at the top.
It is the case that that's always
threatened by malevolence in sin.
It is the case that that can make you
corrupt and cynical and irresponsible.
It is the case that that's the
inappropriate response and that it's
your responsibility to repair the damage
structure of tradition,
despite the fact that it veers towards
corruption.
It is the case that if you take that
responsibility on yourself,
that the rain falls again and everything
flourishes.
It's correct.
It's the right way of looking at the
world and if we didn't know that deeply,
everyone in this room wouldn't have
watched that movie and you think,
well,
it's so strange that we can watch that
movie without understanding it.
Right?
You can fall into it because you do.
When you go to,
you might wonder,
well,
do people have religious experiences?
Because people wonder about the truth of
religion,
let's say,
and I'm not going to go very deeply into
that issue,
but I can tell you that what you're
doing when you go to a movie like that
that has that mythological structure and
you fall into it,
which is what you do,
that what you're having is absolutely
indistinguishable from a religious
experience.
It's the revelation of knowledge that
you know,
but you don't know.
You know,
and there's something about it that's so
deeply engaging and meaningful that you
will line up and pay for the privilege
of being exposed to it,
and this is not an easy thing to
understand.
I think if you bring,
your child will be very excited about
the possibility of going to the lion
king.
Right,
and maybe want to watch it 20 times.
My son watched the,
did the whale scene in Pinocchio,
a bed.
He watched that 115 times when he was
four or five years old.
He just watched it over and over and
over and over.
I thought,
what the hell are you doing,
kid?
You know,
I mean,
it was so interesting to watch that.
He was so obsessed by it,
but there's a tremendous amount of
information in that movie,
like an almost unlimited amount of
information and he was gripped by it and
was trying.
However it is that a child's imagination
tries to come to terms with what the
movie was representing and it wasn't
like he enjoyed it.
Not at all.
Not In the least.
You know?
And if you.
Well,
if you,
if you watch the scene,
how many of you have seen the Movie
Pinocchio?
Okay.
So it's the same thing.
It's one of the 10 most highest grossing
movies of all time.
By the way,
there's a scene where Pinocchio who's
turned in,
he's a wooden puppet who's been turned
into a jackass and for some which is
supposed to make sense to you and
apparently does,
and he goes to the bottom of the ocean
to rescue his father who was somehow
swallowed by a whale.
So think about what you're watching.
You're watching a drawing of a puppet
turned into a Jack Ass,
go to the bottom of the ocean and rescue
his father from a fire breathing whale
and you're all perfectly okay with that.
Right?
So it's very peculiar.
And so,
and it's very frightening.
Like the whale is a while.
It does breathe fire because it's
actually a dragon,
not a whale.
And,
and they,
the animators used locomotive noises to,
to,
to add the audio background and the
whale is hell bent on destroying the
hero of the story.
Pinocchio and also Japan.
And it's a very tense scene.
And so my son was just like this,
like the whole time watching it.
It wasn't.
You wouldn't think that he would,
you know,
he's like these terrified,
like a rabbit who is being watched by a
wolf and then it makes his heartbeat and
these all exhausted and it goes,
and then the first thing he wants to do
is to do it again.
It's like,
what the Hell's going?
Well,
what?
What's going on there?
It's not like it's a cake walk.
It's not that at all.
It's like he could hardly even stand to
watch it.
It's so tense,
especially when you're for.
It's like it's bad enough when you're an
adult,
you know,
and you've seen a thousand things like
that and at least in principle,
your little tougher and a little wiser,
but when you're for that just blows you
away like,
like everything in the world does and
yet all he would do is expose himself to
it over and over and over and over and
over.
And in the lion king,
like if you watch children when they go
see that,
they're just demolished.
When Simba,
his father dies,
right?
Just tears them apart.
They can't believe that you know the
king has disappeared and yet they'll
watch it over and over and over and over
just like you do,
and it's because,
well,
the whole story we used to tell our son
when we took them to movies because he'd
get all shorted out by what was
happening and unsurprisingly,
watch the hero.
Keep your eye on the hero because that's
the pathway through and that's exactly
right because you're supposed to keep
your eye on the hero because that is the
pathway through and there isn't anything
that's more true than that.
That's a true story.
You think,
well,
it's fictional.
It's like fiction presents abstractions.
Abstractions aren't falsehoods.
They're abstractions.
Think about numbers.
Numbers are abstractions.
They're abstracted away from individual
entities in the real world,
but if you know the numbers,
you know abstractions of tremendous
truth.
While the abstraction of the idea of the
individual hero from the collective of
human action is the abstraction of it's
more true than true.
Deep fiction is more true than truth.
That's a way of thinking about it.
It's more real than reality itself.
In the same way that an abstraction can
be more real than the thing that it's
abstracted from all of the,
all of the landscape in a mythological
tale like the lion king is an abstract
landscape.
What's common across all landscapes?
Well,
wherever you go,
there are things that you know and there
are things that you don't know and
that's the human world and it doesn't
matter who the human being is.
You might know more than you do,
but doesn't matter because your
knowledge is still bounded by your
limitless ignorance and the possibility
that that domain of limitless ignorance
will make mockery of what you know at
any moment.
It's a reality and it's a universal
reality and you have to orient yourself
in that landscape
and so does everyone else.
You have to deal with what you knew and
what you don't know everywhere and the
way you do that is by straddling the
divide between what you know and what
you don't know.
You do that by staying firmly grounded
to some degree in what you understand,
but by putting a tentative foot outward
into what you don't understand so that
you can remain stable,
but you can stretch yourself and
challenge yourself simultaneously.
Right,
and that's the proper place to stand and
that's actually a real place.
That's the line between chaos and order
and that's the place of meaning.
Rule six,
again,
real seventies,
do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient and when you do
what is meaningful,
you stay in the kingdom that you've
established,
but you don't stay completely in it
because you need to challenge yourself
and grow and so you put one foot
tentatively out into the domain that
supersedes your competence and you
maintain stability and grow at the same
time,
and when you're doing that properly,
then the psychological consequences of
that is the immersement in a meaningful
experience.
It said deep instinct.
So when you know,
if you watch yourself,
you say,
well,
I had a particularly good day at work,
and what does that mean?
Well,
it means that you lost your sense of
time,
right?
Because when you're having not a good
day at work,
it's like first it's one minute to three
and then it's
45 seconds to three and then it's 30
seconds.
That's what school was like for me.
It was like
click.
So funny.
You know,
I went to,
I went to my daughter's school,
I used to get in trouble for talking all
the time,
surprise,
surprise when I was a kid and uh,
and I was bored stiff in school and,
and so I would misbehave upon occasion
out of pure boredom and vote 21 years
ago I went to my daughter's school to
sit for a class.
It was about an hour long and I was
sitting there and the teacher had all
the kids on the floor and was having
some of the kids read to the others.
And some of the kids who were reading
couldn't read at all.
And I had exactly the same experience.
I was sitting there.
It was like being like being seven years
old,
ugly.
And I could see the clock going,
tick,
tick.
And I thought,
you know,
if I was in this classroom for three
days,
I would misbehave,
fit 40 years old,
I would miss behave exactly like ty did
when I was when I was six.
No.
Well,
that's no place to be right,
because that's.
You don't want to be in a place that
stultifying you don't want to be in a
place where there's no challenge.
You might even quit your job if there's
no challenge.
Say,
well that's a good job.
It gives you security and you think,
God,
I can't stand this.
It's eating away at my soul.
It's all security and no challenge.
So why do you want to challenge?
Because that's what you're built for.
That's what you're built for your built
to take on a maximal load,
right?
Because that's what strengthens you and
you need to be strong because life is
extraordinarily difficult and because
the evil king is always whittling away
at the structure of the state and you
have to be awake and sharp to stop that
from happening so that you don't become
corrupt and so that your family doesn't
become corrupt and so that your state
doesn't have to be come become corrupt.
You have to have your eyes open and your
which sharp and your words at the ready
and you have to be educated and you have
to know about your history and you know
have to know how to think and you have
to know how to read and you have to know
how to speak and you have to know how to
aim and you have to be willing to hoist
the troubles of the world upon your
shoulders.
And what's so interesting about that?
So remarkable.
And this is something that's really
manifested itself to me as I've been
doing these public lectures.
I've been talking about responsibility
to people,
which doesn't seem to happen very often
anymore.
And the audiences are dead quiet.
And I lay out this idea that life is
tragedy tainted by malevolence,
and everyone says,
yeah,
well we already always suspected that no
one has ever said it quite so bluntly,
and it's quite a relief to hear that I'm
not the only person who has those
suspicions.
And then the second part of that is the
better part,
and it's the optimistic part,
which is despite the fact that life is a
tragedy tainted by malevolence at every
level of existence,
there's something about the human spirit
that can thrive under precisely those
conditions if we allow that to occur.
Because as difficult as life is and as
horrible as we are,
our capacity to deal with that
catastrophe and to transcend that
malevolent spirit is more powerful than
the than that reality itself.
And that's the fundamental issue.
I think that's the fundamental issue of
the Judaeo Christian ethic with its
emphasis on the divinity,
the individual as catastrophic as life
is and is malevolent as people can be,
and that's malevolent beyond belief.
Fundamentally,
the a person has in spirit that nobility
to set that right and to defeat evil and
that and that more than that and that
the antidote to the catastrophe of life
and the suffering of life and the
tragedy of life that can drive you down
and destroy you,
is to take on exactly that
responsibility and to say,
well,
there's plenty of work to be done and
isn't that terrible and there isn't
anything so bad that we can't make it
worse and certainly try very hard to do
so,
but I have it within me to decide that
I'm going to stand up against that.
I'm going to strive to make the world a
better place.
I'm going to strive to constrain the
malevolence that's in my own heart and
to set my family's straight and to work
to work despite my tragic loss,
for the betterment of anything,
of everything that's in front of me.
And the consequence of that.
The immediate consequence of that is
that when you make the decision to take
on all of that voluntarily,
which is to stand up straight,
by the way,
with your shoulders back,
to take on that,
all that on voluntarily.
As soon as you make that decision,
then all the catastrophe justifies
itself in the nobility of your striving
and that's what it means to be an
individual.
Thanks.
This one,
this one is good.
The first one here.
What's your take on universal income?
Is it a fast track to new communism,
capitalism killer or a possible way out
of starvation for humanity?
Thank you.
Well,
I don't think it addresses the
fundamental problem.
I think it's.
I think it's a mirror of the rights
responsibility problem.
No,
you might say,
well,
everyone has a right to the basics of
life.
First of all,
that's a debatable proposition because
the question is who's going to provide
those necessities and the answer
shouldn't be someone else under
compulsion,
so
because each rate comes at the expense
of someone else's responsibility and so
you don't want to multiply rights beyond
minimum necessity because you also
multiply diverse responsibilities beyond
tolerance.
But more importantly than that,
I would say is that
let's make it more concrete.
So let's imagine that as the
technological revolution progresses,
more and more people will be in danger
of being replaced by intelligent
machines.
Now we don't know if that's true because
it hasn't happened yet,
right?
And everyone has been predicting that
that was going to happen since like 1960
and it hasn't happened,
and so there may be an infinite amount
of work and we're never going to run out
of work.
I suspect that's probably the case,
but let's assume that people do get
dispossessed as technology's
transformed,
and then we have the problem of the
development of people for who have no
viable means of making a living.
And the question might be,
well,
what's the fundamental problem there?
And one answer is while they don't have
any money,
but I actually don't think that that is
the fundamental problem.
I've had many people in my clinical
practice who were unemployed and had
money.
Now they didn't have a lot of money,
but they had enough money and enough
money to keep privation at bay,
let's say,
and enough money to.
Well that was the rub,
enough money to get themselves into
plenty of trouble
and so one of my clients,
for example,
was a.
I liked him quite a lot and he had,
he was,
he had worked in a hospital and he'd
been hurt and and then he got onto
painkillers because he'd been hurt and
then he got addicted to painkillers and
then he got addicted to cocaine and his
life took a bad nosedive and he is
actually pretty good unless he had
money.
But as soon as he had a check,
it was,
he was gone.
He was in a ditch,
he was in a bar.
He spent all his money and he was face
down in the ditch and that's where he
woke up the next day.
And the reason I'm telling you that
story is because it wasn't that he
didn't have money.
That wasn't the problem.
Really.
The problem was that he didn't have a
purpose.
He didn't have a place anymore.
He got thrown out of the structure that
would have enabled him to find
productive meaning,
you know,
when you might've said,
well,
he should have been able to conjure that
up on his own and perhaps that's the
case.
Although he wasn't the world's most
sophisticated person,
you know,
when people very substantially in their
sophistication and it and he didn't have
a good family,
he didn't have a support network around
him.
He was kind of a last character in many,
many ways and so it was easy for him to
fall out of the world,
which is what he did and providing him
with money was not going to fix that and
says what is going to fix that?
Well,
that's a good question.
I mean,
we,
we have a program,
some of you people might be interested
in it,
it's called.
It's part of a suite of online writing
programs called the self authoring
suite.
It's outsell faltering Dotcom and one of
the programs is called future authoring.
And we've experimented with this program
in an attempt to address this problem.
Okay.
So I mentioned to you tonight idea that
we live out a story and we need a
purpose to live out that story properly,
and what that implies is that you need a
purpose.
You need a point,
you need a name,
you need to precise same.
You need an aim that's of sufficient
nobility.
I can't think of any other word,
sufficient nobility to justify your
miserable existence even to yourself and
you need to develop that aim.
And so we built this program.
I started working on it about 15 years
ago when I was giving my students
exercises to do university and one of
the exercises I had them do was that
they had to pick a small problem maybe
in their family or their room and fix
it,
not try to fix it,
but actually pick a problem that was
small that they could fix,
clean up the cigarette butts in the
yard,
outside the residence,
clean the room.
We had one kid whose mother had died in
the family,
got kind of fragmented and he decided
that he was going to take over the
maternal duties in the household and the
kids were supposed to write about what
happened when they tried to put this
into practice because doing things like
that is way more difficult than anybody
ever realized this.
And so he tried to become mother and the
family needed a mother and he,
he encountered all sorts of terrible
resistance,
which is completely unsurprising.
I mean,
first of all,
people in his family were annoyed that
he would dare to try to take their dead
mother's place,
you know,
even though he was trying to do it for
the best of reasons.
And we played with that for a couple of
years and that was very interesting.
And then I realized that I was teaching
students all these stories about
purpose,
but nobody had ever had them write a
story about their purpose essentially.
So I thought was not interesting.
Here are these,
these,
these kids,
they've been in university,
they've been in school for 15 years
and no one has ever sat them down and
said,
well,
what sort of character do you want to
develop?
Who should you be and why don't you
write that out and justify it,
you know,
six pages,
something like that with the same amount
of care and attention that you might
spend,
or even more on an essay about the war
of 18,
12 or something like that.
Think,
well,
when the more I thought about that,
the more
flabbergasted I would say I became
because I thought,
well,
what that,
what,
how is it possible that we could set up
our education system and run people
through it for 15 years and never have
them forced so to speak,
to figure out who they wanted to be in
to justify it in an articulate manner.
And so I built this program with my
colleagues to help people do that.
I used my classes first and so I
thought,
okay,
well here's the game and this is like
rule to treat yourself like you're
someone responsible for helping.
And that doesn't mean be good to
yourself.
It doesn't mean me be nice to yourself.
It doesn't mean give yourself an easy
life that isn't actually what you do to
people.
If you care for them,
you actually present them with something
like an challenge.
That's what you do with kids.
If you love them,
as you present them with an optimal
challenge so they can develop and grow.
So that's what you should do for
yourself if you're taking care of
yourself.
So I thought,
okay,
well here's the game.
First of all,
assume that you're worth taking a care
that we are worth taking care of and
that it's your responsibility to do so.
Even if you don't like yourself very
much and lots of people don't and they
have their reasons because everybody is
very aware of their own flaws,
right?
Unless you're narcissistic,
you're more aware of your own flaws than
have anyone else's flaws and maybe
you're not very happy with yourself and
you don't think that you deserve to have
an okay life and so you punish yourself
and you set yourself up for failure and
all and all of that.
Now it happens all the time or you just
don't aim or you don't have any goals or
you know you're guilty and resentful and
feel that you should be punished,
so you have to abandon all that.
Treat yourself like you're someone
you're responsible for helping,
responsible for helping.
Imagine yourself three to five years
into the future.
You get to have what you need.
If you're taking care of yourself,
you can have it,
but you have to figure out what it is
because you are not going to get it
unless you aim at it,
and that's rule 10 is be precise in your
speech.
And the reason I wrote that rule is is
because you can be bloody sure that
you're not going to hit a target unless
you a matte it,
and the more precise you make the
target,
the higher the probability that you'll
aim at nothing.
You'll hit it when you aim at it.
So what do you want?
And you think,
well,
I don't want to even think about what I
want because as soon as I figure out
what I want,
then I've made clear Mike conditions for
failure and it's the last thing I'm
going to do.
And so people envelop themselves in
vague this so they don't have to
confront their own failure,
but then they fail and just don't notice
except for maybe you know,
two decades later when it's too bloody
late and then they're all catastrophic,
really hurt because they wasted their
life.
It's a very bad plan.
It's better just to figure out what you
want and to tell yourself and then to
tell your partner and to tell the people
around you and maybe you can get it or
maybe at least while you're struggling
towards it,
you'll come up with a better plan,
which is more likely the case.
What do you want from your family?
If you could have what you,
what was good for you?
What do you want from your intimate
relationship?
How are you going to educate yourself?
Because you don't know enough.
What do you want for a career or job?
Because not everyone has a career.
How are you going to spend your time
outside of work in a productive and
meaningful manner?
How are you going to resist the
temptations of drugs and alcohol and
sexual misconduct,
let's say,
because those are the big three.
How are you going to maintain yourself
physically and mentally?
While those are seven good questions,
you can have what you want.
What do you want?
It's an operational realization of the
new testament principle.
Ask and you will receive knock and the
door will open and you think,
well,
there's no possibility that that's the
case.
It's like actually it is the case.
If you don't specify what you want,
you won't get it,
and if you specify what you want and you
want it,
which means you're willing to make the
sacrifices necessary to get it,
then the probability that you'll get it
expands immensely and miraculously in
some sense.
Now,
of course,
it assumes that what you want is within
the bounds of appropriate reason,
let's say,
but you could also dream big and there's
always the possibility that'll work out
too,
so people as answer those questions,
then they write for 15 minutes,
okay,
your life is the way you want it to be
in four years.
What does it look like?
Right?
As much as you can,
don't worry about being too accurate.
Don't worry about grammar or spelling.
Don't worry about getting it right
because you're not going to get it right
anyways.
Just sketch the damn thing out.
If you could have what you wanted,
what would it be,
and then we have them do the opposite,
which is,
all right,
take stock of yourself for a minute with
all your weaknesses and inadequacies and
bitterness and resentments and sinful
tendencies.
Let's say.
Now,
imagine that you let all of that goal
and occupy you just wear which little
corner of Hell would you occupy in three
to five years?
Why don't you write about that and
everyone knows where they go.
If they let themselves and so then you
have something to avoid and you have
something to strive for and that makes
you optimally motivated because maybe
you're afraid,
you know,
you find out you don't like your job and
you're afraid to change your job and
then you think,
oh,
well,
if I don't change my job,
then I'm heading for this little corner
of Hell that I outlined.
Think,
well,
that's not a very good plan.
It's very threatening and stressful to
change my job,
but it beats the hell out of ending up
there.
And so then you have your anxieties
behind you pushing your forward instead
of in front of you,
stopping you cold.
And then we asked people to write a plan
to implement their paws division,
to justify it,
to come up with a strategy for,
for making it into a real world
realization.
And we tested that on thousands of
university students now and the upshot
was that it decreased the probability
that they would drop out of university
by 30 percent.
In fact,
in Canada we did it for 90 minutes
before kids went to college in the fall.
They came to their summer orientation,
neither road for 90 minutes about
something that required writing,
but it wasn't so relevant or they wrote
out a plan and it dropped the dropout
rate among young men 50 percent in the
first semester and it had the biggest
effect on young men who didn't do that
well in high school and who weren't
oriented towards a professional career.
The consequence of that was that the
university used it for one year and then
stop doing it.
So which was not surprising in the
least,
but the reason that I'm laying out this
long story for you is because that's
what people need.
They need.
They need a differentiated and
delineated purpose.
It's way more important than the money.
It isn't money that you need.
I know you need money for God's sake.
I'm not ignorant.
Everybody needs money.
That's not the point here.
It's the provision of money without
purpose is not helpful and what people
need is a purpose and they need that to
develop that for themselves,
obviously because it's something you
have to participate in,
but it's something that society has to
foster and the reason they need that
purposes because that's what gives their
life meaning think,
well,
think about this.
Do you really think that you would be
satisfied if you had money without
responsibility?
So what?
Okay,
got no responsibility because that's
what everyone wants.
It's like I had a client,
he wanted to retire when he was kind of
young and he and I said,
well,
what's your retirement dream?
He said,
well,
I envisioned myself on a beach in a
tropical island with a Margarita in my
hand.
And I thought,
what the hell is that?
It's like,
okay,
let's play that out.
Let's be adult about this.
Okay,
so you go down to your this red headed
white guy,
you go down to the Caribbean and you sit
on a beach and you're sitting on the
beach and you have like six Margarita
and you're there for like three hours.
What happens the next day?
Okay,
your Sun burnt to a crisp,
right?
So you can't even go out of your hotel
room and you're hung over.
Okay,
and let's say now you hide in your hotel
room for three or four days and you
recover and then you repeat that every
day for three months.
It's like you go outside and all the
locals get away from you because you're
the new drunk lecture who's come down
from the north and that's your vision
for retirement.
It's like,
okay,
so you have all the money.
You want no responsibility.
You don't take care of yourself.
You don't have a partner,
so you don't have to take care of them.
You don't have any kids.
You don't have to take care of them.
You don't have a job like,
what are you going to do?
What are you going to do?
Exactly.
Sit in the sun and Drink Margaritas.
It's like there's no.
No,
that's not a good vision.
You don't want no responsibility.
It's wrong.
People find the meaning in their life by
adopting responsibility and so
provision of money.
You know,
they say,
man does not live by bread alone,
and there's wisdom in that.
It's like you don't want no
responsibility.
You might dream about that if you're
crushed by your job,
but then you have the wrong job,
or do you have the wrong attitude or you
have the wrong job and the wrong
attitude.
I don't know what it is.
You want lots of responsibility and
society needs to foster that and we need
to help people find their purpose and
their place and that's,
that's more to the point than universal
income.
It's the wrong solution.
Thank you.
So that is the solution for the
individual,
but for an individual that takes your
program and authors,
his or her future already has taken the
first steps of response,
personal responsibility by doing
something about it.
So let's assume that we hear we,
we assume responsibility for our lives.
We get our act together and we start
with our rooms and we,
we,
we broaden the circle and we want to
start helping people out in the world
that don't have this first seat of
responsibility.
And of course some of them will also
have diseases that they can't do
anything about.
We can leave that aside
for now,
but what do we do to inspire others?
Well,
you just laid it out.
I would say it's like you know,
one of the things that you.
You pull out of the clinical literature.
Imagine that you have children who have
a certain low level amount of
neurological trouble when they're
infants,
so something's gone wrong.
Maybe a little oxygen deprivation at
birth or something like that.
Something's gone a little bit wrong with
their neurological development.
Assuming that the damage isn't too
severe,
those children will stabilize and
normalize if they have at least one well
put together role model in their life.
And so one of the things that you do if
you want to inspire others,
is get your act together because you
inspire most through example.
It's more much more powerful than the
words.
Words are very powerful if they're also
accompanied by example,
but the best thing you can do is start
putting things together around you.
There's plenty of things to put
together.
It's a good meditative exercise.
You know,
if you're,
and I think this is the proper form of
prayer,
let's say assuming that there is such a
thing,
a proper form of prayer would be if
you're not happy with your life,
if you're miserable,
you sit on the edge of your bed and you
think,
is there anything I can change in what
I'm doing that is going to make this
less awful than it has to be less awful
than it might be.
You have to ask that.
You know with intent and generally
speaking,
you'll get an answer almost immediately.
There's something that you could put
right that day that would make things
slightly better than they are,
and that's rule four,
which is compare yourself to who you
were yet to who you were yesterday and
not who someone else's today.
There I don't believe that there is a
person who exists who wouldn't receive
an answer to that question if they
genuinely asked it and it's no different
really than thinking like if you think
you have a problem,
you think you get an answer might not be
the right answer,
but obviously you get an and you might
think,
well,
I thought up that answer.
It's like,
well,
that's really not much of an explanation
because you don't know how you think.
It's like I'm sitting there and thoughts
appear in my head and that's how I
think.
That's a pretty shallow explanation.
It's not much different than revelation.
It's like you ask yourself the proper
questions.
You'll get the proper answers if you ask
the right question and you want the
answers right and those are not easy
preconditions to set up because who
knows?
You know if,
if you're sitting on the edge of your
bed thinking,
okay,
what am I doing wrong?
That's a hell of a question to ask
because if you really want to know,
you'll find out and then you'll find out
that you really didn't want to know
because generally speaking,
finding out what you're doing wrong is
not a pleasant experience and it means
that you have to sacrifice part of
yourself,
usually a burned out,
stupid,
bitter,
corrupt,
arrogant,
nasty,
vengeful part of yourself,
but nonetheless part that you like and
so
so you can.
I think that room for those incremental
improvements exists within everyone's
grasp and and I think that it's a humble
thing to do,
to ask how you could improve
incrementally without interfering with
anyone else.
Like it's your problem,
not theirs,
but I think that the consequences of
maintained incremental improvement are
anything but incremental.
You get compound interest on incremental
improvement.
No.
There's another rule in the New
Testament called the matthew principal.
Economists use it and the rule is to
those who have everything more will be
given and from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken to actually a
description of the way the world works.
Interestingly enough,
you know that if you've ever played
monopoly,
because that's what happens if you play
monopoly and and there's a reason for
that,
that's a deep reason,
but what,
and it's a very harsh rule because it
means as you start to wander off the
path,
let's say the probability that you will
wander further off the path increases
nonlinearly and that's a terrible thing
to know as you wander towards the edge,
the probability that you'll fall off the
cliff increases and that's a statistical
justification for the concept of hell,
but as you improve the probability that
each improvement will produce a further
improvement increases,
and so perhaps the the downside is the
cataclysmic catastrophe that you can
engage upon if you reproduce your moral
failings,
but the upside is that each improvement
produces an increment in the probability
of the next improvement.
And I've seen that it's a truism among
behavioral psychologists.
I mean,
although they don't generally phrase it
that way.
If you're a behavioral psychologist and
I am a behavioral psychologist,
what you do is you find out what
essentially you help a person establish
their aim.
Then you break down what they're trying
to do into attainable units and you
negotiate with them.
You say,
well look,
while I'm not,
they say I'm not making use of my time
very well.
Spending three hours a day playing video
games and you say,
wow,
okay.
Hypothetically,
how much time would you like to spend
playing video games?
And they say,
well,
I could probably spend an hour a day
without it interfering with the rest of
my life,
which is kind of the issue,
right?
Because if you play video games,
fine,
but maybe three hours means that you're
not doing your homework or something and
that's not a good game.
So you say,
okay,
well I want to play for an hour a day.
It's like,
okay,
well can you shift to an hour a day
right now?
And this is supposed to be an honest
conversation,
and the person says,
no.
I've tried that lots of times.
Every time I try I just fail.
And so you don't say,
well,
quit failing.
Go play one hour a day and the problem
will be solved.
That's a stupid strategy.
You say,
okay,
well look,
you think about this and don't agree to
do this unless you think you will do it,
because otherwise it's just a waste of
both of our times.
It's like,
do you think that you could track how
much time you spend playing video games
for one week?
Don't change anything,
just track it.
They think,
yeah,
I could probably do that,
but I might miss a couple of days and
you think,
okay,
fine,
so here's the deal.
Five out of the next seven days,
you just track how much time you spend
playing video games and the person says,
I think I can do that,
because that's what you want them to
say.
You want them to succeed at.
The improvement is not much of an
improvement,
but it's something,
right?
Then they come back and they say,
well,
yeah,
I was playing about four hours a day,
and so you say,
okay,
well fine,
good work man.
You got track.
Now we know what.
We know the parameters of your problem.
It's actually a little worse than you
thought,
but at least he had enough sense to
measure it.
We know where you're at.
Okay.
Do you think you could cut that down to
three and a half hours every day
and the person thinks,
no,
I'm pretty weak willed.
I don't think I could manage that.
You say,
well,
how about this?
Do you think that to have the next seven
days,
you can only play for three hours.
You think you can manage that and you
don't.
You're not cynical about this.
You're not insulting the person,
any of that.
It's like because you don't care.
All you care is that they make some
incremental movement towards their goal
and the person thinks about that.
If they have any sense and they take
their weakness into account and they
think,
I think I could probably do that,
and then they come back the next week
and they say,
I managed to spend three hours a day
playing video games for three days and
the rest were four hours,
and you say,
good work,
man.
You've just got rid of 25 percent,
12 and a half percent of your problem,
your one eighth of the way to fixing it
in one week and you know the person
isn't going to be all that thrilled with
themselves because they don't do the
arithmetic and they don't do the
projection.
They think,
well,
I'm still pretty damn useless.
I'm playing 25 hours worth of video
games a week.
It's nothing to pat myself on the back
for.
It's like,
yes it is.
It's definitely,
it's a market measurable improvement and
it's a move in the right direction,
you know,
and then you say,
okay,
well on the days you succeeded,
how did you manage to succeed and is
there a way that you could do it for
four days next week?
How about that?
Or maybe you could even try five days.
You think you could do that,
and then you also tell the person,
look,
the other thing you got to understand is
you're not going to improve like this.
You're going to improve like this.
So some weeks you're going to come back
and say,
Geez,
I backslidden completely and I played
for four hours a day for seven days,
but doesn't matter because that doesn't
mean you failed.
It just means that you slid back,
you want to calculate it over a month or
something like that.
And you know,
generally speaking,
a month later,
the person's down to something like two
hours a day and you've figured out ways
of filling their time in with something
productive otherwise and,
and they're on their way.
And the general consequence of that is
that every time they manage an
accomplishment,
they get a little stronger and
character.
They get a little bit more confident in
their ability to get a little bit less
wracked with self disgust.
They get a little bit more hopeful about
the future and they get more confident
that they can make another change.
And if you're patient and you have to be
patient with yourself that way,
it's like you reward those incremental
improvements and you don't get all
cynical about them and you think,
okay,
just imagine what would happen if you
kept doing that every week for 10 years.
And the answer to that is things would
be so much better for you that you can't
even imagine it without much improvement
or maybe even with half that much
improvement.
And so that's a,
that's a very good way of progressing.
So very good.
So
yeah,
there's a question here on the article
written by your friend Bernard Schiff.
That's one of the many headpieces.
So yeah,
from via that healthy.
I want to ask you what your thoughts are
of the article written by Bernard
Schiff.
Kind of a wide question,
but I'd like to hear your side of the
Mat.
Okay.
So Bernie Schiff is a friend of mine,
although he doesn't see it that way.
Well,
I'm not saying that to be funny.
Like that's how I look at it and it's a
loss to me because he was a good friend
of mine.
I've lost a couple of friends in the
last two years and it's two or three
years and it's not pleasant,
but he had his reasons for doing what he
did,
which I won't go into,
but there is one thing I will say about
it.
He set forward a set of propositions
about the way that I was interacting
with my students and am interacting with
all the people like you to whom I'm
lecturing and he's he questions my
motivations and fair enough,
but
he said,
for example,
I'm paraphrasing,
but this is the gist of it,
that my style was autocratic say in the
classroom,
and he cited a couple of students who
felt that way and I would say,
I'll say two things about that.
The the
evaluations of my classes at Harvard and
at the University of Toronto.
We're almost invariably better than the
evaluations of any classes they'd ever
had.
That's the first thing in my maps of
meaning class.
The most common comment,
and that would have been from about 80
percent of students was that the class
completely changed the way they
conducted their lives.
So that's issue number one.
Issue number two is all those lectures
are online,
like not every lecture I've given in the
last 30 years is online,
but every lecture I've given in the last
four years is online plus one lecture
series that I gave 30 years ago and a
whole bunch of other talks.
And so if you want to see whether the
accusations leveled at me in that
argument in that article are true,
all you have to do is go watch the
lectures and if you think they're true,
well then he's right.
And if you don't think they're true then
he isn't right.
The d,
The evidence is,
it's not like it's hidden.
I've been recording my lectures since
like,
well I recorded one in 1993 at Harvard
and so it's online and then there's like
200 hours of them.
So whatever my crimes,
they're there for everyone to see and to
determine for themselves.
And so that's mostly what people are
doing and um,
that's fine with me.
So.
And that's pretty much all I have to say
about that article.
Thank
you.
There's a question from a Mcdonald's,
a relating to what you discussed
earlier,
nuclear weapons.
What are your thoughts on mutually
assured destruction?
Will we be safer in a world without
nuclear weapons?
I think it depends on how we decide to
conduct ourselves.
You know,
it isn't obvious to me that we're in a
position where we can trust ourselves
without nuclear weapons.
You know,
nuclear weapons are like,
they're like a judgmental God in some
sense.
If you miss,
behave too badly,
there's going to be hell to pay,
and so the consequence of that,
since the end of the Second World War,
thank God,
is that no one has misbehaved too badly
yet,
and so I don't know if that's.
We've had comparative piece since the
end of the Second World War.
Now that doesn't mean there hasn't been
caught chronic low level conflict and
some of it.
I'm not saying that the conflicts have
been trivial,
but compared to world war two,
they are trivial and certainly compared
to world war three,
they are trivial.
And so I would say that the hydrogen
bomb has put the fear of God into us and
that there's some utility in that
obviously it would be better if we
didn't need that because they're
dangerous and the probability that
there'll be an accident at some point
seems to me to be 100 percent because
there's always an accident.
Right?
And so we're playing with fire.
But,
but it isn't self evident to me that so
far it's been a bad thing.
Even the,
even the Soviets,
even Stellan,
although he was probably,
there is some evidence that stelling
Stellan was gearing up for the Third
World War and that he would have been
willing to put Europe to the
thermonuclear torch.
And he was just the kind of guy to do
it.
He'd been practicing doing that for a
long time.
After you kill your 10000000th person,
the next 10 million come pretty easy.
And so he was.
There is evidence that he was gearing up
for that in western Europe and that he
was probably killed.
And so,
but apart from stolen,
no one has come along who's been corrupt
and malevolent enough to make that a
priority.
And so that's
so far a testament to the fundamental
goodness of the human heart.
But what do you think Hitler with have
done with nuclear weapons?
I think he probably would have cleared
out most of eastern Europe
being part of his plan.
I mean you perhaps know this,
but Hitler believed the Germans deserved
an empire like many other east,
many other European countries had an
empire and he felt that it was no
different for the Germans to pursue
their empire than it was for the British
and that his empire was going to be in
eastern Europe because what the hell
good are they?
Anyways,
that was his attitude and I think he
would have used whatever means necessary
to clear out as much territory as
possible so that it could have been
inhabited by his voke.
That's what it looks like now.
You know,
you might ask about credit have been
done by nuclear means and the answer
that's probably so I think he would have
put them to use.
I mean,
my sense of Hitler,
you say,
well,
what motivated Hitler?
You say,
well,
he wanted to rule the world.
It's like,
I don't think that's what he wanted.
I think he got exactly what he wanted.
He wanted to put a bullet through his
head when Berlin was in ruins and Europe
was inflamed.
That's exactly what he did.
And you think,
well,
no one could aim for that.
It's like,
think again,
someone named for it and they got it
too.
So I don't think he would've stopped.
So,
um,
there's a question here regarding the
controversial
statement three regarding enforced
monogamy.
So
from DC,
three question stating the obvious often
suggests an agenda.
I agree with your observation that lack
of sex for young men can make society
more violent.
What should be done?
That's actually not my observation.
So that isn't my observation.
Amen.
In words matter,
my observation is that social norms
favoring monogamy are essentially a
human universal.
And the reason for that is that we've
learned through painful experience that
social conventions,
favoring monogamy are the best way to
reduce male violence,
provide a secure environment for
children,
and help women find partners to help
them with the difficult process of
reproduction and child rearing.
And that's the.
The woman who wrote that article knew
perfectly well that when I used the term
enforced monogamy,
and we only discussed this for probably
two minutes out of an interview that
lasted two days.
She knew perfectly well that I meant
social convention,
but it was in her interest to find a
phrase that could be misinterpreted so
that what I was speaking about could be
misinterpreted.
So here's what enforced monogamy means.
So let's say my son is planning to get
married in the fall.
And all right,
I'm happy about his fiance.
We seem to get along quite well.
They seem to do quite well together.
And so I'm pleased that they've made the
decision to start their life together.
So now imagine that he comes to me any
here and he says,
I've got some news for you,
dad.
I've been married for a whole year and
I've managed to have three affairs
during that time,
not get caught and what am I supposed to
do about that?
Hey,
what do I put my arm around them and
say,
good work kid way to be.
It's like no.
First of all,
if he did that,
he wouldn't tell me and second,
if he did tell me,
which I can't imagine,
I would ask him just what the hell did
he think he was doing that that was no
way to conduct himself and it would be
something I would regard as contemptible
not only the affairs but the deceit that
goes along with it and the violation of
his vows and the breaking of the
harmonious relationship that he decided
voluntarily to establish and the
weakening of the family structure and
the trouble that he put everyone through
to attend the marriage ceremony in good
faith and all of that.
While it's that's enforced monogamy for
God's sake.
It's the.
It's the assumption of the
responsibility on the part of people who
enter a relationship with some
expectation of permanence to uphold the
promise that they make when they do
that,
and she knew that bloody perfectly well
and so it's just a,
it's so idiotic.
It's almost impossible to believe,
you know,
first of all,
if you're going to accuse someone of
something,
you should at least accused them of
something that's plausible.
It's like,
would there isn't anybody who goes
around thinking that monogamy should be
enforced at the point of a gun,
you know,
maybe the odd isis wing nut does that,
thinks that,
but no,
there isn't anyone who thinks that is
including me and she knew that perfectly
well and so if that's the best that my,
those who regard themselves as my
enemies on the left can manage as a
character slurred then well,
you know,
have outer boys and girls.
It's pretty bloody pathetic as far as
I'm concerned.
So
thank you.
I'll tell you one more thing about that.
Here's something interesting.
I detailed this out in 12 rules for
life.
I don't have the figures exactly right
because I haven't got to memorize,
but you know,
over the last 20 years the desire for
marriage has increased among young women
and by a substantial margin.
I think it's 35 percent,
something like that.
At the same time,
it's decreased among men by about 17
percent.
It's like,
so why am I telling you that?
well,
are we so blind that we don't realize
what most people want?
Like most people who aren't cynical
dream that they'll find a monogamous
partner.
You think,
well,
what's the evidence for that?
Well,
first of all,
there's evidence for that because all
you have to do is ask people and the
majority of them tell you that,
but there's way more evidence than that.
It's like,
what do you do?
You take your date to a romantic comedy
and what's the structure of the romantic
comedy?
Man Lies to partner and has multiple
affairs and you go away from that
romantic comedy and you think that was
fun.
Let's do that.
It's like that isn't.
What happens is you go to a romantic
comedy together and you see a couple who
are attracted and repulsed across the
across the dynamics of the movie and
they overcome a bunch of obstacles and
they decide to live happily ever after
and that's the romantic comedy and it's
like a sure fire success if it's
reasonably handled because it reflects
what people want and the reason that
reflects that is because basically,
although not without exception,
human beings are monogamous,
we tilt towards monogamy.
That doesn't mean we can't be serially
monogamous and it doesn't mean that
there aren't people who tend towards
multiple partners,
but it's not the dream.
That's for sure.
It's not what we enforce social norms.
It's not the universal human standard.
It's not what makes for good people,
individuals or good intimate
relationships or solid families or
stable communities and so and I don't
know how that can be contentious.
How did that become contentious?
What's the alternative
like?
Responsibility lists,
impulsive sex.
It's like,
do it,
man,
do it for 15 years.
See how much fun it is.
See where you end up.
You will certainly end up cynical.
You'll definitely end up alone.
Well then what the hell are you going to
do?
What are you going to do when you're 45
and you don't have anyone?
Now,
what are you going to do for the next 35
years?
You don't have kids.
You're not going to have grandchildren.
You don't have someone to tangle your
story together with.
You don't have anything that lends
solidity to your life.
You've got no responsibility and so no
self respect.
Oh,
if that's what you want,
if that's what you're promoting as an
alternative to enforce monogamy,
it's like have added to your life.
You'll see.
That's my sense of it,
so
thanks.
No,
here's a good one.
What can mark system contribute to our
modern day world by
it can contribute Venezuela and it has,
and it has.
I'll be a little bit less cynical in our
hands,
but
we've seen what it can contribute.
I don't know how many bloody times we
have to run the experiment.
No,
that wasn't real Marxism.
I know what that means.
I know what that sentence means.
What that means is,
well,
if I was the dictator with my profound
understanding of Marx's real intent and
my benevolent compassion uncontaminated
by any proclivity towards darkness or
sin,
I would bring on the socialist utopia.
That's what it means fundamentally,
and if someone says that and claims it,
then you should get the hell away from
them as fast as you possibly can.
Okay,
so mark's was concerned about inequality
and there are reasons to be concerned
about inequality,
but the problem with Marxism is that it
lays the cause of equality at the feet
of the fundamental institutions of the
West.
The free market,
democracy,
capitalism,
patriarchy,
the hated word,
inequality is not caused by the
institutions of the West.
That's wrong.
Inequality is the fundamental rule of
existence,
and it's produced.
The thing about the western systems,
every system we know produces inequality
when it's run as a,
as a,
as an operative process,
all of the systems produce inequality.
What we've developed in the West is the
only system that produces wealth along
with the inequality,
and you might say,
well,
the wealth isn't equally distributed.
It's like that's true,
hence the inequality,
but at least there's some wealth.
You know,
the number of people in absolute poverty
in the world have to between 2000 and
2012,
three years faster than the UN was
hoping for in its most wildly optimistic
projections.
People are getting comparatively richer
at an absolute level with unbelievable
speed.
It's never been seen in the entire
history of the planet first.
It happened in the West,
obviously including to Iceland and even
in the last 75 years here.
This has been an unbelievable increasing
the standard of living and now it's
starting to happen everywhere else.
This fastest growing economies in the
world are in Subsaharan Africa.
That's a hell of a good deal.
There's no starvation in China.
There's no starvation in India and in
the places in the world where there's
still is starvation.
It's because because of political
reasons,
it's not because there isn't enough
food.
It's because one group of people sets
out to star of another group of people
to death.
It's not a matter of absolute privation
or because of Marxism.
Well,
yes,
because of mark says,
right.
I think the average Venezuelan has lost
something like 17 pounds,
you know,
it's very,
it's awful.
It's absolutely awful.
So I don't think that Marxism has a damn
thing.
I think Marxism has already contributed
enough millions of corpses to have
finished with its contributions
personally,
but it isn't Marxism thing just because
it has its appeal and its appeal comes
from grains of truth that had uses and
tries to stretch across an explain,
allowing the Marxists point to the
pernicious problem of inequality and
inequality is a problem of inequality is
a problem.
I mean,
I outlined that in part in 12 rules for
life.
The reason there's a left wing and the
reason there should be a left wing is
because inequality is a problem.
It has to be addressed and when you set
up a hierarchical structure,
which you need to,
if you're going to pursue things of
value,
then the hierarchy tends to ossify and,
and,
and become rigid and it becomes hard for
people at the bottom to climb to the top
and so they get dispossessed and that
can become permanent.
That's a bad thing.
It's everyone's problem,
left wing centrust,
right wing doesn't matter.
Inequality is a problem,
but that doesn't mean that you can lay
it at the feet of the institutions of
the West and that's where Marxism goes
wrong.
And it also doesn't mean that we know
how to fix inequality.
It's really a hard problem and so it,
it's a much harder problem than people
think.
Now when we don't know what to do about
it.
We've done some things and you know,
our culture is very.
The Scandinavian countries tend to be a
little bit more on the income
redistribution side and that seems to
have worked reasonably well.
I mean the Scandinavian countries are
pretty damn livable.
They've got their problems,
particularly Sweden as far as I can
tell,
but,
but it's easier for homogenous small
countries to do risk redistribution by
all appearances.
It's not so easy for a place like the
United States,
which is much bigger and much more
diverse and has a much broader range of
problems.
And so the western countries are
stumbling through.
Some of them have steeper hierarchies
and less of a social safety net like the
US.
Although it's incredibly productive and
tended to have very low levels of
unemployment and then there's places
like the Scandinavian countries where
the social and Canada where the social
safety net is more well developed,
but that struggle with,
with,
with improving productivity and with
higher rates of unemployment most of the
countries.
So we don't know how to get that right,
but we're kind of muddling through it
and at the same time we're muddling
through it.
Almost all of us are getting absolutely
Richard and so that's a pretty good
default position to be in when you're
trying to sort out the inequality
problem and you know,
I've been thinking over the last weeks
that there are,
you know,
you can express these problems in quasi
mathematical form.
It's like there's probably a rule that's
something like in order to produce one
increment of absolute wealth,
you have to allow three increments of
inequality or something like that.
Inequality is the price you pay for the
generation of wealth.
And I suspect because the right amount
of inequality,
the right amount of inequality is not
zero.
It's some number.
And you could debate about what that
number is,
but it's not zero.
You flattened everyone out,
you get nothing if you have a
meritocracy of some sort than if you're
producing something to get to the top,
uh,
you know,
producing something for others.
Well,
the thing is,
is that the radical types believe that
they don't believe that there's anything
but power they don't want.
Another thing that really annoys me
about the universities and this doctrine
that I've been
combating,
let's say,
is that
your argument is predicated on,
on the idea that there's such a thing as
merit,
that there's such a thing as things
worth doing.
And the real radical types would debate
that.
They just say,
well,
you're just using the idea of
meritocracy to justify your page,
your position in the patriarchal
tyranny.
And you might say,
well no,
I'm not.
And they would say,
you're just a mouthpiece for your group
privilege.
There isn't any.
You don't make that mistake.
There's no you,
you're just
an Avatar for your privilege.
So.
Well,
thank you.
Well know.
So before I ask the last question,
I'd like to remind you that we were
going to meet outside this room and more
people may come since the people from
yesterday,
they,
they may come as well and Dr Peterson is
going to sign books and if you're going
to have books signed,
you'll have a few seconds with him.
Um,
so,
um,
yeah,
the last question,
we had a similar question yesterday.
A very original one from savannah.
Thank you.
So honored.
How do you like Iceland?
Um,
well my wife and I,
well I'm here actually with my wife and
my mother who I don't normally travel
with and my aunt and they came along for
the adventure because I had invited
them.
I'm traveling with my wife to many,
many places and I asked members of my
extended family if they wanted to have a
bit of an adventure that they could pick
a place to come.
And My mother and my aunt picked Iceland
and everyone here has been ridiculously
hospitable.
And so that's lovely.
And I've met lots of people in the
street and outside these venues and
everyone has been unfailingly polite and
welcoming and you have a beautiful
little country and what you've done with
it is nothing short of miraculous as far
as I'm concerned.
It's beautiful,
it's peaceful,
it's thriving,
it's stable,
it's free.
It's like great.
I love,
I love coming to countries like this and
I do think there are absolute miracles.
Life is a real catastrophe.
And yet look at how wonderful it is here
and it's not like it's easy.
This isn't an easy place to live.
It's a hard place and yet you've.
You've done a tremendous amount with
what you have in front of you and so
more power to you as far as I'm
concerned.
I've had a wonderful time here.
Thanks very much.
It's been a real honor to be here and to
talk to all of you.